877 on c-span for pricing information or
to request a tape
roger kimball is an art critic and
managing editor of new criterion a
monthly review of arts and culture
in august of 1990 he was a guest on book
notes to discuss tenured radicals how
politics has corrupted our higher
education
it's a critical review of some
university professors and the social and
political ideas they're teaching in the
classroom it's about an hour
did our higher education
why do we need a book like this
well primarily because
our higher education
is in a state of crisis
i think that on many colleges and
universities
we have a situation where politics has
insinuated itself in the most
fundamental way into the teaching of the
humanities
and um it's a situation that not only
college students but their parents
alumni trustees and common citizens must
take very seriously if they care about
the future of
education and our culture where did you
go to school i went to school as an
undergraduate at bennington college in
vermont and as a graduate student at
yale university what years
let's see i guess i graduated bennington
in
75 and was at yale from
76 until in 1983 as a graduate student
in teaching
did anything that you wrote about here
happen when you were in school oh yes
it's uh it's this is not entirely a new
phenomenon i would
date its um uh primary origin to the
1960s although i think we've seen in
recent years an acceleration of the
trends that i described in these in this
book
the institutionalization of radical
feminism of deconstruction of ethnic
politics of a very radical sort i think
has gotten a lot more steam
as it has become institutionalized in
the curriculum obviously we don't have
students
marching on the ramparts anymore what we
have is professors who assimilated that
that radical ideology teaching classes
we have deans who agree with that
radical ideology
forming curricula we have provosts and
presidents who agree with that radical
ideology shaping the
future of our education do you have a
favorite professor that you remember at
bennington
uh yes and someone who would would be um
absolutely opposed to the uh the radical
trends that i described in this book
he he or she wouldn't favor what's
happened no he he would uh uh
he is as appalled as i am at what's
going on in higher education what did
you like about him and you want to name
him claude fredericks he was my greek
tutor
at bennington i majored in philosophy in
classical greek
he
is a a very cultured man with a wide
appreciation of
world literature
understands that
teaching and learning is
not a political matter but is you know
something that involves individual going
out of himself or herself to meet ideas
that are very different from the cliched
ideas that um we are bombarded with in
the marketplace and on tv and popular
novels and so forth what was your major
in bennington it was philosophy and
classical greek was a double major
why do we really care about
what happened in greece and with the
greeks well because we can't really
understand ourselves
we can't understand our own civilization
and our place in it unless we understand
what made us and a large part of what
made us is the greco-roman tradition
it's not the only thing there are other
elements as well but that's essential
for being an educated person and
understanding where we came from
you used the word earlier deconstruction
yes what does that mean that is a uh a
very popular literary theory which um uh
in essence and i'm simplifying but in
essence uh holds that uh
language is so
imperfect as a means of communication
that it never really gets outside itself
it never really reaches reality it's
self-referential in the deepest sense
and so it tends to be associated with a
very radical skepticism sometimes
nihilism
and it's
is very popular in the academy and
in one version or another
has become
a dominant
factor
in the teaching of the humanities not
only in literature but also in history
even in the law
where we're told that
the laws really don't have anything to
do with justice they're really only
about power relations and that sort of
thing so it's a very a very corrosive
ideology i believe what is a humanist
well um obviously it's a it's a term
with a long and very complex pedigree
going back to the renaissance i think uh
today in the sense which i would use the
term it's someone who has respect for uh
the important traditions that have made
us someone who
views education and culture as
precious and fragile
inheritances that must be preserved and
the best way to preserve them is
to study them in a dispassionate uh
which is not to say uninterested
and committed way and i think that
many of our so-called humanists
professors of english of philosophy and
so forth today
are anything but humanist they tell us
about the end of man the end of the
human uh they're interested in uh
they think they've gotten to the truth
when they've uncovered as much untruth
as possible
the the place of radical skepticism and
nihilism about um human relations uh
about the achievements of our culture um
is uh business as usual in the academy
today and i think it's something that um
anyone with an interest in culture and
an interest in the future of our
civilization has to take very seriously
and be alarmed about
what is nihilism
nihilism is the
belief that nothing matters that
we are
puppets to
power relations that
we
all of the traditional things that we
thought gave meaning to life are
actually frauds
and the nihilist
his interest in learning about things is
really to expose them to demythologize
to debunk
denials to someone who
for whom values our
kind of hypocritical
codification shall we say uh that has
been imposed upon us from above where
does the term come from it comes from a
latin uh term nihil meaning nothing it's
very
very aptly named uh term i think do you
believe in god if you're a nihilist
no i think by definition denialist is
someone who
programmatically does not believe in god
but
loves to talk about
what dupes other people are if they do
believe in god or have any spiritual
commitments of any type you're managing
editor of the criterion new criteria the
new criterion yes it's a monthly review
of
the arts and culture based in new york
city who buys it
uh well um a lot of our enemies buy to
find out uh what's wrong with themselves
i suppose but a lot of artists buy it
university libraries buy it people who
are interested in what's going on in the
cultural scene both in new york and
other places who do you consider to be
your enemies
well
people who programmatically try to
distort the truth people who uh um
attempt to
sell
[Music]
blatant trash as high art people who um
well i should say as art people who
would deny that high art
is a cogent term or that it's to be
preferred
in the realm of culture to something
that's either trivial or trashy
people who
espouse a virulent left-wing politics um
those are some of our enemies are you a
virulent right-winger no i'm not what
are you
uh well i used to think of myself as a
liberal but um i've been told that
that's not uh not the case i guess the
the term that's usually applied is
neoconservative which i think
irving crystal wants to find is a
liberal who's been mugged by reality i
suppose that sums it up pretty well
where'd you grow up uh in in cape
elizabeth maine just south of portland
how did you get interested in greek
philosophy
oh
i suppose um
uh probably in high school i became
interested in philosophy i went to a
jesuit high school in maine and
had a little bit of philosophy there and
sort of pursued it in college if you've
got a free night nothing to do and you
want to you got time to read a good book
what will you pick up
well um it's true that i do sometimes
pick up plato or aristotle not as often
as i i should um
very rarely do i pick up a contemporary
novel usually i will read
and read or reread an older novel that
troll up dickens something like that
that
i find that very entertaining who's your
favorite philosopher
um
immanuel kant
why
well i believe that he was
a philosopher who
really helped us understand uh not only
the way we think about the world what
knowledge is how we what truth is but is
also a philosopher that emphasized to my
mind in a very productive way
the virtues of freedom and
and understood very clearly what
that freedom goes hand in hand with
responsibility and that
to pretend that uh free you can have
freedom without responsibility and duty
uh is a pernicious illusion
any other philosophers you follow
uh well i mean i've been influenced i
suppose by many philosophers by by plato
by aristotle i mean everyone who we all
are whether we know it or not um i
suppose uh
schiller's um contemporary i'm sorry
kant's contemporary uh schiller is
someone who i also think of as uh
very important to my thinking because of
the the way in which he uh discussed art
and the importance of art and the
aesthetic
modifying some of the theories of
immanuel kant
do you ever have you have any theory at
all as to why you or anybody gets
interested in this kind of thing and
holds on to it for the rest of their
lives versus would you say the
overwhelming majority that if you ask
them who emmanuel khan is they wouldn't
have a clue
well they probably have heard the name
um
there's no reason why
the man in the street should be
intimately acquainted with the works of
emanuel kant however i think a college
graduate ought to have read something of
kant's i think his education or her
education is
uh incomplete without without that
um
why one gets interested in it i think
it's a multiplicity of factors it's
probably some something native
inclination
teachers i think are very important the
teachers you have especially in high
school who can awaken your curiosity in
these matters and in college
more students than i can
account have been turned off uh from
philosophy from literature by a bad
teacher um
and i think uh if we paid more attention
to teaching especially at the secondary
level we'd find that more people were
interested in in their the great
heritage that's uh made us what we are
this book is published by show the
audience it looks like harper rowe sells
for 18.95
who do you think will buy this
who is buying it that you know well uh
certainly a lot of academics are buying
it
making them mad well i think it's making
them quite quite angry
i think a lot of parents are buying it
people who are interested in what
they're spending uh 20 or 1000 or more
dollars a year on
i think college administrators are
buying it
and people who are uh who are outside
the academy but who are interested in
culture who are interested in what's
going on and want to see whether things
are really as bad as they may have
suspected from
the news that's been leaking out from um
not only from my book but elsewhere
how do you know that this is going to
make people mad has anybody come up to
you in this process oh sure well
it certainly made some of the reviewers
uh angry i've gotten many letters many
of them supporting me but a fair share
of of angry responses from academics
i've lectured around and have been
called fascist for example for some of
the views that i put forward here
i think that the main thing is that
to understand is that these champions of
freedom and pluralism are only uh
interested in
excuse me supporting those values
insofar as it's um
uh
insofar as you agree with them about
what freedom means and insofar as you
agree with them about what pluralism is
if you show any signs of dissent then uh
they very quickly retreat to calling you
all sorts of names like um
a reactionary fascist conservative that
sort of things those are all
epithets negative epithets in their in
their vocabulary
tenured radicals what does tenure mean
well the the title uh is an attempt to
blend together two things that we don't
normally think of as going together
tenure is a an academic institution
which secures someone's employment for
life
it was instituted
in an effort to protect
academic freedom freedom of expression
to foster diversity of opinions on
campus
uh
radicals uh means uh in its root meaning
it means a root something that goes to
the very essence of uh of uh whatever
subject we're talking about um and in
this case it means a political radical
someone who uh in the deepest sense
feels that his culture uh that
the tradition that he's been entrusted
with to pass on is uh corrupt and needs
to be overthrown so what we have here is
a very unusual situation of people who
are
guaranteed employment for life who are
seeking to undermine the very thing that
they're supposed to um supposed to be
championing and protecting have you ever
been a college professor yes
ever been tenured no you ever want to be
tenured well i thought at one point in
my life that i would like to uh i would
like to devote myself to um
scholarship and writing and reading
about these things into teaching
but i soon discovered that the academy
was not the place for someone of my
interests and
predilections is it because you didn't
have a chance of being tenured because
of your views in your opinion no i don't
think so it's i was interested in more
i write about a great many subjects the
academy has become very specialized
recently so um if you're not going to be
uh
to specialize very early and very
intensively it's extremely difficult to
get tenure at any but
really sort of rather far-flung
institutions and i wasn't uh interested
in going
far afield from from new england how
does tenure work
well um uh it has become a kind of
parody of the process that it was uh
first intended to uh embody in the sense
that it's become very routinized and
it's become a means of ensuring
conformity of opinion rather than
diversity of opinion um
typically a young professor will uh
get a one or two year contract and then
another two or three year contract and
then come up for tenure after a certain
number of publications and so forth and
the guidelines are very rigorously set
down
but
lo and behold it turns out that only
those or mostly those who
share the ideology of their colleagues
who after all are sitting in judgment
over them
actually get tenure so that
i don't want to overstate the case but
far from merit being the only uh
criterion i think that ideology has more
and more uh come to play a role and
indeed uh not so long ago the supreme
court
enshrined that role by saying that
if any of a wide number of
perceived victim groups and any member
of a wide number of perceived victim
groups felt that they had been unfairly
denied tenure because of their
sex race whatever they could
automatically appeal
so that the criterion more and more is
shifting to political things rather than
uh rather than intellectual
accomplishment or pedagogical skill you
wrote about that uh decision that was in
1990 this year yes i guess it was
earlier written by justice blackmon
that's right and you suggest that uh
because of that decision that the
records that are kept on the university
campuses about professors would be
available for people to see if they
didn't get tenure uh well the the one of
the dangers is that uh that the uh
process of confidentiality by which
tenure decisions are usually
made
can now be violated
if there's any question of
discrimination but what this means of
course is that uh it will become harder
and harder for professors to
give their candid opinion about uh
a candidate if they know that what they
write
might be available for public scrutiny
tenured radicals is the book how
politics has corrupted our higher
education by roger kimball and in the
book uh
roger kimball you write about you keep
mentioning three people i i must have
read it ten times and you mentioned them
in a group allen bloom lynn cheney and
bill bennett and you keep saying that
those three people get under the skin of
your tenured radicals why well i i keep
mentioning those three people because uh
the enemies of the tradition keep
mentioning them i think that
all three have contributed a great deal
to our understanding of uh the the
plight of the academy today um when you
say academy what are you talking about
i'm talking about um colleges and
universities
any college
i use that as a kid yes i i'm mostly
concerned uh in this book with
the top echelon
of our colleges and universities because
it is uh those institutions i think that
set the pace that are models for other
institutions and it's those institutions
that are the intellectual leaders or
should be the intellectual leaders um
most concerned with passing on uh the
tradition that uh that has made us what
we are okay let me ask you about the
three would you tell us who alan bloom
is
yes alan bloom is probably known to most
of your uh viewers as the author of the
closing of the american mind which is an
indictment of um
uh the spiritualness of higher education
today do you like that book yes i did
and you point out a couple of times that
he's a democrat
uh yes it's because he's widely
perceived as uh as conservative if not
indeed reactionary so i thought and and
often uh described as reaganite
so i thought it would be just to set the
record straight it might be useful to
mention that he's at the university of
chicago he is indeed is he tenured oh
indeed yes yes he's not however a
tenured radical at least not in the
sense in which i uh i suppose i supposed
to hold a conservative position these
days on any educational matters itself a
sort of radical position so in one sense
i suppose you could be said to be a
radical by the way have you ever seen
figures on the final
number of uh closing the american mind
books that were sold yes i have i
believe it sold somewhere in the
neighborhood of a million copies
altogether does that surprise you that
yes i i think it was a uh
a tremendous surprise i'm always
reminded of the the new yorker cartoon
where there's a huge stack of uh of the
book and uh the bookseller is
advising
a potential customer said oh um i
haven't read it of course but it's a
great book
and i think many people bought it and
did not read it but i think that the the
great success of that book uh shows that
there is a um
uh
that bloom hit a nerve that people
really are interested in in in the
academy in matters of education and
what's happening to their children uh in
in college uh are they are they being
taught what they should be taught uh uh
or and
he showed very graphically that in many
instances they are not and you know
people are understandably very uh very
interested in finding out about that
uh lynn cheney
lynn cheney is currently the chairman of
the
humanities endowment uh she uh
is very concerned with with these issues
and has written and spoken out very um
uh very well i think uh on them she is
um uh in general i would say on my side
in this in this issue a republican and a
conservative um i i actually don't know
what party she's in i assume uh uh
since her husband is the secretary of
defense that she probably is republican
but i don't actually know
and uh finally the third member is bill
bennett yes uh mr bennett was
chairman of the national endowment of
the humanities before
linchini and then went on to become
secretary of education under president
reagan and is currently the so-called
drug czar
i think he together with alan bloom did
more than anyone to spark a
sort of national interest in this in
these issues
mostly by a pamphlet that he released
when he was
jointly authored but that under his uh
leadership when he was chairman of the
national endowment for the humanities
and i mentioned these people as
frequently as i do in the book
because as i say the the the academics
who who they attack
have just been
apoplectic
about
the criticisms that have been launched
against them and so it's um i'm
interested in a sense not so much in
what they have to say individually but
just uh as instances of the way in which
um uh
the sort of dominant uh trend in the
academy today brooks no criticism are
you an absolutist in the first amendment
uh no i'm not
how do you deviate well i i guess
i believe that the first amendment was
written to ensure freedom of political
speech primarily and that
to
to apply it to
other
really quite different issues
is to court danger for example to invoke
the first amendment to protect
pornography
i think is
a debasement of what the first amendment
was about
i'm not a legal scholar so
maybe i'm on shaky ground there but this
is not to say that i would support uh
censorship even of pornography but that
i think that it's a debasement of what
the first amendment was intended to do
to apply it to uh to in that way
what i was really getting at is that do
you think that on a college campus that
the students should be able to hear
in lecture series or whatever any
thought that any person would want to
lay down yes
yes i do and in fact i think that the
widespread recent trends on on our
campuses uh to limit free speech
that is to say limit free speech that
offends the reigning liberal ideology in
the academy
is a very worrisome
trend and this is one instance at least
where i am on the side of the aclu in
looking with great skepticism and alarm
at campuses across the country that have
enacted this uh so-called
anti-harassment legislation which uh um
as one student at stanford said well it
may not be in accordance with the first
amendment entirely but then i'm not so
sure that it should be because after a
while we're out to show the world how we
should really live we're out to make the
world a better place there's a kind of
moral self-righteousness involved in
what's going on in this respect that i
think is very worrisome indeed you
mentioned that your favorite
philosopher's probably [ __ ]
yes would that be a favorite philosopher
of most neoconservatives
um
uh no probably not i'm not really i
think neoconservativism has really uh
uh a very
disparate
set of origins and um
uh i think if anything distinguishes uh
them it's really their diversity and um
i mean it's not as if it's a monolithic
movement where there's a sort of
agreement about everything it's quite
the opposite i think okay tell me help
me with this then if if you're a
conservative let's just divide the world
just for talking purposes and to
conservatives and liberals
if you're a liberal
who are the philosophers that name more
than one that you
probably like
yes i think here we have to introduce
one uh wrinkle because as i said earlier
i used to consider myself a liberal
but have been told that i'm not because
uh you know the traditional liberal
would say
we want a society where
one important value is equality of
opportunity we don't want to legislate
equality of condition i think that's a
that's an old-fashioned liberal position
we want a society where advancement is
on the basis of merit not on the basis
of gender uh or race that's an
old-fashioned liberal position these
positions are now
under attack not only in the academy but
in our society at large they're
considered to be reactionary positions
so i feel as though i have sort of
stayed in one place and the culture
especially academic culture has moved
really quite noticeably to the left i
mean traditional philosophers that have
uh
underpinned uh liberalism are you know
locke is a very important one john locke
the english philosopher um i
you know in his social philosophy i
think he had a lot to teach us he is one
of the architects philosophical
architects of our constitution and
indeed emanuel kant is a liberal uh
you know in in most respects um so but
not by today's standards you see it's
it's because words like freedom and uh
when it's conjoined with uh with duty
and responsibility that's that's very
suspect to our new liberals
where do people like aristotle plato and
socrates fit in all this
well it's you know it's of course uh
you're going back over 2000 years you
have uh you know vastly different uh
social conditions no people will tell
you if you uh
if you support um the teaching of plato
or aristotle they that they advocated
slavery and so forth and wasn't this
terrible um but of course that's to
import our very different values now
back uh into uh you know the distant
past i think that they between them uh
the three of them they virtually defined
uh all of the philosophical questions
with which we are still struggling as uh
another philosopher alfred north
whitehead said
all philosophy is really a series of
footnotes to plato
and i think that's true it's uh we
really are all footnotes uh in one sense
or another struggling to uh to confront
these questions many of which don't have
answers but they they define who we are
as human beings struggling in the world
to understand ourselves and others
let me try something out on you based on
what some of the things you said in your
book i recently talked to a a
college student
who was studying uh the judicial system
and one of the assignments that
this student got was to read the book
presumed innocent
and then as a class go see the movie
yes well i think that's really a
terrible waste of money would be
interesting to calculate how much it
cost
for that class uh you know if it was a
if this school costs 20 000 a year and
you have so many classes a year so i
wonder how much that cost i mean any
student who is uh intellectually alive
and curious is going to go see the
movies uh
they're going to go
and uh read popular novels we don't um
go to college to have our
the prejudices of the sort of dominant
culture around us reinforced we should
go to college to to learn about things
that are different uh i mean the word
education means in its etymology to lead
out from uh i think that uh that the
demand for relevance is really misplaced
it should be turned the other way around
we should ask not uh is plato or
aristotle not are they relevant to my
experience rather is my experience up to
plato or aristotle after all that's what
education is about is learning about
something more to go outside of yourself
to gain a wider deeper perspective you
don't do that by studying the texts as
they do in some colleges of mtv
or watching movies or um uh you know
reading uh uh trashy novels uh i think
it's a fraud on the students let me try
something on yeah and i don't know that
i can articulate this very well but some
people feel
and some i don't know what that word
means but i've i've heard this or we've
talked about it or read about it that
the difference between thomas jefferson
and james madison is that somebody saved
all of jefferson's papers and madisons
were burned
is there a chance that in history there
could be somebody out there in history
that could be a lot smarter than say
kant but
their papers weren't saved and why
should we follow kant
and not the other person and why should
we follow jefferson and not madison that
that all of this that that you're saying
in the past is based on whether or not
somebody thought enough of what they
said to save it well there's two things
to be said about that one uh is i i
certainly would support the effort to uh
historical research to resuscitate
neglected authors
thinkers who have been unduly passed
over i think that's marvelous if we
discover a
a female contemporary of shakespeare who
wrote even better plays i'm all in favor
of that that's terrific uh but um
unfortunately we have to
being mere mortals we have to deal with
the tradition that we have
it's i think it actually is unlikely
that there was another philosopher
around the time of kant who came up with
the same ideas and so forth but um you
know i suppose it's a metaphysical
possibility but it's merely a
metaphysical possibility our task
as citizens of the united states in the
late 20th century is to deal with um you
know history as as we have it um if it's
true that uh that all of madison's
papers were burned and so forth and so
on and he might have been a bigger
influence well uh how do we know that a
and b
if they are they are there's nothing we
can do about it so we have to work with
what we've got well i guess i was
getting at the in the thing that you've
been most criticized about is
criticizing those segments of the
academic society that want to focus on
women's studies or black studies or
anything other than the white male
historical figures that get all the
attention why not well first of all i
think that it's a it's a caricature of
what i recommend doing to say that i
want to study only white males i mean
somebody i would put at the very center
of an english curriculum for example is
jane austen who i think is one of the
greatest novelists uh that that we have
um
i mean the
the sad fact i guess it's a sad fact is
that um uh throughout history most of
the important authors uh that
that should say the people who have
created the intellectual tradition that
we're dealing with most of them have
been male uh now
you can say that's a terrible thing you
can deplore the social economic
conditions that um that made that uh a
fact but it is a fact and
pretending otherwise is not going to
change that fact and if you want to
criticize the tradition that's fine but
you first have to learn about it and i'm
all for reading women authors if you
study japanese literature you have to
read the tale of the genji lady murasaki
i
mean
george elliott and so forth and so on um
was there a playwright writing around
shakespeare's time who was a female who
was as important no and uh you know
digging up some third or fourth rate uh
female playwright and pretending
otherwise is again a fraud on the
students it's a waste of time and money
and it's it's a it's uh pushing an
ideological agenda in a place where it
doesn't belong what's uh so great about
shakespeare well i think uh you know
that he is someone who it was able to uh
show in a very concrete immediate and
gripping form uh the vast panoply of
human experience
not only english-speaking peoples but
around the world at least around the
european world
shakespeare is held as a kind of epitome
of
of
the highest dramatic art he was able
to
show so many human characters uh engaged
in very passionate immediate
circumstances and uh
in a way that is both uh moving uh and
and beautiful um i mean
what makes any great literature great i
mean shakespeare in a sense had it all
it seems to me
is there a chance that somebody in the
in this century
could have written great books or movies
or fiction or whatever it could be just
as talented as say something like
shakespeare was sure of course there's
also the problem though as samuel
johnson once uh put it talking about
milton and shakespeare uh i believe it's
milton and shakespeare that you know
priority means something when somebody
does something first it stands as a
model in a way so that
it's unlikely that they would have the
same sort of effect partly because
shakespeare's been around for 400 years
his phrases have infected or
affected the way we we think about
things he's he's become part of the
language uh if someone were to write a
series of plays that were
just as brilliant
just as moving just as immediate just as
funny
touching
as
shakespeare now
he would have to wait a long time before
his
before his effect could really be fully
felt
tenured radicals is the book roger
kimball is our guest this is uh in your
bookstores
back to the tenured thing um
once you're tenured
what does it mean what kind of freedom
do you have as a college professor
well generally tenure is uh uh
is a contract between you and the
university that you will be given
lifetime employment
for rendering your services as a
professor in most places you can be
relieved of tenure only for a gross
moral turpitude uh or
if there is some very radical shift in
the
structure of the university so that for
example the whole department were
abolished what is gross moral
interpretation well that's uh that's
that i guess that depends um uh you know
it's it's common i think for professors
to uh convert romantically with students
these days so i guess that doesn't count
but i'm sure that uh oh i don't know
child molestation might do it uh that
sort of thing is it possible if you're a
tenured professor that you can basically
do nothing but show up and still keep
your job oh yes in fact um uh it's uh
it's regular
i mean that's uh i do i i
myself have been very lucky in my
teachers i've had
both at bennington at yale a uh
a string of very devoted teachers but
the the professor who who receives
tenure and then sits back and does
virtually nothing is uh
you know a blight really
there's no way for the university to
move them
uh not without a very expensive lawsuit
universities don't even attempt to get
rid of people with tenure anymore
because
when they've tried it's cost them too
much can a university get rid of 10-year
period
uh it would be a tremendous fight and
it would it would be very difficult i
think in this day and age to do so it
would probably all things considered be
a good thing
why well i don't wha who do we who has
uh the guarantee of lifetime employment
why should do professors really need
that is our culture so
monolithic uh and has free speech been
limited to such an extent that we have
to worry about um
about uh having tenure to protect free
speech i don't think we do that's the
reason for tenure and uh
as i say i think it's it's by some
insidious process has turned
turned into an institution that has uh
really required conformity
uh intellectual conformity it has not
fostered diversity i think it would be
an interesting experiment to try a
university without tenure and see what
happened uh you know in the businesses
of this country we don't have tenure we
serve at the pleasure of um of our
superiors generally uh what makes
university professors so special why why
should they be given this special
dispensation
can't you i know you can hear the
professor sitting out there listening to
you saying i'm glad that bird isn't in
charge of my university i didn't have oh
well i don't know i don't get me out of
there because of his political views
alone well you see i i hope i wouldn't
and but if you can't blame someone who
uh who has a tenure for not wanting to
give it up that's i mean purely
self-interest you can't uh i wouldn't
expect them to uh to to be on my side on
that issue i think it's a complicated
issue because uh you know uh there was a
time
that you know these were real issues
that freedom of expression on our
campuses was uh threatened and it's um i
think it's threatened now from the left
i think that there is a kind of
intellectual conformity uh of opinion in
our campuses and uh you know colleges
and universities that uh uh is almost
monolithic i mean if you just look at
the uh the the political persuasion of
the your typical college academic it's
something like 90 percent uh democratic
you're right about stanford
and uh the president of the university
kennedy don kennedy
and bill bennett got into that one do
you want to review
what happened out there yeah so i think
the the reason stanford the stanford
controversy generated so much
controversy
more heat than light perhaps is is that
it was taken as a um
really an exemplary instance of what was
going on all over the country here you
have a great university uh that is
really one you know one of the foremost
universities in the country and they had
a series of courses designed to
introduce students to the
great works of western civilization
under great pressure from both faculty
certain faculty members and certain
student groups
they decided to scrap this
series of courses in favor of one
that was
designed to institute the new
multicultural
ethos of of the late 80s and 90s a kind
of course where instead of uh
you know reading plato one would read or
watch movies about navajo indians
instead of reading john locke one would
read the revolutionary terrorist franz
fanon that sort of thing uh this is not
to say that they there are also some
traditional books in the course as well
but the the bias of the course was very
clear it was as jesse jackson said
leading some students chanting there hey
hey ho ho western cultures got to go it
was a deliberate attack on western
culture and the values that it that it
embodies and um bennett made so much of
it because it's uh as i think a
frightening prelude to what we see at
many other colleges and universities
around the country
why isn't jesse jackson right but what's
so good about western culture well
western culture
is good in any number of ways um
one is politically and socially it's
been
the culture that preeminent among world
cultures has worked for the uh the
freedom of the individual the dignity of
the individual it's uh
the culture among others that has uh
preeminent among others that has been
economically the most powerful it's the
capitalism uh western invention has been
the greatest economic engine in the
history of uh
of the world it's a culture that has
produced monuments of uh of literature
of art of philosophy um it's i think
very very much worthy of preservation
and the i think unthinking animus
against western culture in our colleges
and universities is something that is
comic in a way because
these are beneficiaries of the western
tradition who in any other tradition or
most other traditions wouldn't be
allowed to voice criticism of of their
uh of the dominant culture and here are
sort of doing so in a kind of
play-acting way uh and but it's also
deeply and disturbingly ironic because
they don't seem to realize that the
achievements of our culture
are achievements and they're fragile and
can be uh
disrupted and undermined in ways in
which they would not like at all if if
what they advocated really came about
if western culture is so good
and so important why did
it take
minorities and women
so long to get the same rights that
white males had well i mean but it's you
know it's a product of western uh
culture that now they do and i'm not
saying that western culture is perfect
i'm not saying that there aren't lots of
problems that there's that there's not
discrimination in this country still
there is i mean that's a fact um but uh
the i mean the real question is uh why
was it that it was here first that they
they got these rights i mean it's uh you
know we're dealing with an imperfect uh
an imperfect universe and uh to you know
utopian thinking say well gee couldn't
it be perfect someplace else well uh
where else are you going compared to
what are we criticizing western culture
compared to uh a fundamentalist islamic
regime would women prefer to be there i
don't think so uh and so you know when
when we raise these questions we it's
always a comparative matter we have to
say uh compared to what is is are we
criticizing western culture i'm not by
the way suggesting that we should go
blindly on and not criticize what's
going on around us i think we have to
engage in a continual process of
criticism and
challenging and we you know trying to
make our culture better than it is but
the way to do that is not to throw out
the achievements that we have that we
have made are you advocating inclusion
of a certain number of
western philosophers and artists and all
that uh
an exclusion of the fannins that you
mentioned earlier and what is it is
there something you don't want taught uh
no well i i hear it's partly a practical
matter but there were other
considerations too the practical matter
is that college education lasts four
years uh you have so many hours to read
to think to study
and you have to pick and choose among uh
say a thousand candidates of things
maybe more uh you can't read all those
things so you you you pick what in the
judgment of people who have been
studying and thinking about these things
are the most important uh things to
study read think about um
and that obviously leaves out a lot but
i think that the real question is for um
for these students who are devoting
themselves to this what what is the best
that's what you want to give them now we
might disagree about certain things but
actually i think most people would agree
that on this list of the best plato
comes aristotle comes uh shakespeare
comes dante comes you know it's not a
it's not a uh it's not a difficult
process there there are some questions
around the edges if you know if we have
time we'll read this or that or the
other thing now i believe that franz
fanon belongs not in a course uh on
western civilization but perhaps a
sociology course about the terrorism or
a history course about uh
you know about african independence
that's that's a separate issue of course
then he should be taught then but to
institute him in a as a kind of an
integral part of a course designed to
introduce you to what western
civilization about seems to me to be
again
a fraud on the students because there
are other things that are more important
and be a blatantly political move on the
part of radicals to uh insinuate that
the western tradition is
sort of fundamentally corrupt let me try
this on if you had a choice of the bible
or the teachings of buddha
would you want the students to have only
the bible
only the teachings of buddha or both
well i would in a perfect world i'd like
to have them have both i think that in
our culture the bible has been
you know incomparably more important the
cadences of the king james bible
affect everyday speech they're
strewn throughout our literature they
have formed the way we think in the most
fundamental possible way
the teachings of buddha have not i you
know i'm all for reading about the
buddha i think it's you know i mean any
educated person should know something
about the world religions uh
in this culture the dominant uh uh
influence though is the bible not the
teachings of buddha
uh let me see if i can try this one okay
in the middle east there's lots of
problems and we've had nothing but bad
relations with iran for the last 12
years the koran
the islamic teachings all that area
wouldn't it be more used to us to study
the problem that religion and why
they're acting the way they're acting
over there in the middle east versus
the bible
no i don't think so because i think that
uh
it's important for us to understand who
we are first uh i mean we're talking
about literature courses and so on i
mean i i think actually that um one
would gain uh less insight into the
islamic personality by studying the
koran uh than by studying the
actual political development of of iran
now i think it's uh you know that's not
to say i don't think we should read the
quran sure i mean why not it's a it's an
important book it's uh and islam is an
important religion but uh i think that
that you know our first task is to
understand ourselves before we attempt
to uh
you know uh sort of go further afield
you live in new york city yes what do
you think of it
oh it's uh it's the best of times the
worst of times it's you know it's a
great city but it's a city plagued with
very uh serious problems that seem to be
getting worse
if you have a free moment and music is
your uh
your interest where would you who you
listen to where do you go
well i want to go to carnegie hall
there's often good concerts there uh but
what kind of thing do you choose based
on your you know your interest in your
background your studies well i suppose
my interests are primarily in uh two
things uh chamber music and um
early music those are my two
main interests in music who are your
favorites well um i'm
very quite passionately uh interested in
um uh people like yom de macho is a very
early composer i love
string quartets you know going much
later haydn and that sort of thing uh
mozart probably maybe my favorite
composers mozart
if you've got an afternoon to go look at
art what would you what would you go for
get any choice anywhere
what kind of art would you look at uh
well my tastes there are
pretty
wide i guess i suppose my absolute
favorite painting is a
17th century italian paintings the met
has a marvelous collection
and we talked earlier about what you
would read
who do you think writes the best
who who's the best who are two or three
of the best writers
uh
right now that you know of in anything
if you had to go pick somebody based on
their writing talent who would you pick
a novelists
just writers
who does good writing
well it's a tough question isn't it uh
i'll leave myself out of course um don't
put yourself on top that's fine
um well actually just i'm sure this is
uh if i had more time to think about i
might come up with different candidates
but uh since i'm just reading a new book
by his uh there's a polish philosopher
named leche kolokovsky who english is
probably his tenth language but i think
he writes
extremely well
and very trenchantly and very movingly
about
subjects of great importance he teaches
at the university of chicago and is
well worth anybody's time i think
um
i'm not terribly fond of the
sort of our contemporary fiction so i
wouldn't pick a fiction writer um
anybody that writes for a newspaper that
you you read all the time daily
newspaper do you think
well i can't say that uh that um
any of our daily papers really uh the
the quality of the reporting or the
opinion pieces really seems to me to be
absolutely first-rate going up down
you'd see a trend well i think actually
if you compare uh say the new york times
today uh to what it was even 15 years
ago the quality of the reporting about
cultural matters anyway has taken a
precipitous drop
the range of reference the um the kind
of knowledge that could be assumed in
the part of the audience um has taken a
very noticeable drop i mean it's quite
actually quite stunning to go back and
read uh the art page at the new york
times for example in the early 70s as
late as you know recently as then and
compare it with what's going on now i
mean that the change is like night and
day the the uh seriousness with which
our cultural matters were addressed the
um
quality of the writing uh
the kinds of subjects that were
addressed the range of intellectual
interests was vastly superior then to
now what about television you spend any
time watching it um well i did as i was
growing up last i do not have a
television at the moment
so i don't very much how long have you
not had a television
since i moved to new york so i guess
since 1983. and you think you're better
off by not being able to watch no i i'm
one of the liabilities of living in new
york is that uh
apartments are very expensive and have a
very small apartment so i mean if i it's
not i don't have a television not by
design i you know i can imagine having
one it's just
i don't find it indispensable to my
daily life cape elizabeth mayne's where
you grew up yes what were you what'd
your parents do
uh well my father worked for my
grandfather who had a business that was
located uh primarily in cleveland ohio
and my mother was a housewife when did
you find yourself first getting
interested in all things intellectual
like in high school was the uh what was
the reason well the the jesuit teachers
that i had i think uh
they first introduced me to milton for
example uh uh today carte
renee de carth the great french
philosopher
i started reading latin then and so
forth it was really the influence of my
teachers at uh in high school who
awakened
what intellectual curiosity i have so it
was strictly the high school experience
and the teachers did have a significant
impact yes
indispensable i would say
the reason i ask you all these questions
is whether or not i want leading up to
whether or not you think we're the whole
in this country based on your book here
tenured radicals if it's having an
effect
uh in your opinion on the country that
everything is in decline
well one doesn't want to be a a gloom uh
merchant uh and say gee everything is uh
worse now than it used to be uh even if
that's true um i think we know we're
making progress uh in some areas
technology and so forth um but i think
that um
any dispassionate observer who compares
what's going on in the cultural realm
now uh to what was going on you know 10
20 30 years ago
it's very difficult not to conclude that
we're in a period of
decline and probably decadence i mean
take the recent uh uh to move out of the
academy for a moment but the recent um
uh kind of brouhaha over people like
karen finley the performance artist who
smears herself with chocolate and so
forth and dances around the stage naked
and
sort of
mouthing lots of politicized slogans is
that high art
should that be supported by taxpayers
money
is it a
curtailment of free speech to say well
no this shouldn't be you know i i
believe that
absolutely in karen finley's right to do
this i also believe that it's garbage
and should not be supported by taxpayers
money
in the in our colleges and universities
the
insinuation of politics
the uh trivialization of the curriculum
where people watch movies and read
popular novels rather than studying the
monuments of civilization uh i think
this is a decline it's a sign of decline
it's a sign of lack of seriousness about
culture and about what intellectual
achievement means and it's something
that people should be very worried about
what in your opinion should every
college student have to take in in
school well we would spend the rest of
the uh of the show if i were to start
giving a list
we don't have much time so let's try it
let's see give me give me some give me
that they have to take should they all
have a foreign language yes in a liberal
arts college also i think a foreign
language is indispensable if you're
studying engineering should you have a
foreign language um yes i think that an
educated person would should study a
foreign language not doesn't mean that
he or she has to become proficient in it
but i would say that uh we're talking
about a four-year liberal arts school
even if the student majors in in
engineering yes what about uh history
what kind of yes well i think that we
certainly should have american history
i mean our ignorance of our own
tradition is uh appalling uh uh and i
think that uh some kind of uh for
students who are not majoring in history
some kind of uh survey of you know uh
of the western tradition from greece and
rome through the renaissance european
history is indispensable but about
philosophy
i think that probably at least one
course in philosophy should be uh should
be talked and that would be a kind of
introduction to the philosophical
problems that could be historically
based beginning with plato and aristotle
and trying to understand the kinds of
problems that they articulated or it
could be
oriented around
specific problems and deal with the
wider sort of
bunch of philosophers scattered
throughout history should any college or
university offer
uh black studies lesbian studies women's
studies all those things that you get
upset about should that be an offering
anywhere
well i i'm against departments in those
things certainly and um
which is not to say that i don't think
we should shouldn't study women's
literature or black literature um
[Music]
i'm very i very much worry about those
kinds of labels though i think that um
they are meant of course to uh to
empower these groups i think they wind
up by uh to use a term that they often
use ghettoizing them because uh um i i
suppose i'm an old-fashioned
integrationist i believe that you know
that
what matters most is our common humanity
not our gender or the color of our skin
and i think that you know to to
focus on something like um women's
studies or black studies is to uh is to
threaten to cover over that thing and uh
i think it tends to be divisive rather
than liberating
i don't know this is fair but if there
was somebody that you would pick to sit
in that chair that has the direct
opposite point of view that you have but
intellectualizes all that who would that
be you know you mentioned a number of
them in your book who do you like on the
other side that you'd like to debate in
the subject the most
well that would be a lot of people i
mean say stanley fish somebody i talk
about in this book
frederick jamison of colleague of his
they both teach at duke they both
i'm sure would disagree with every
syllable uh that uh that i've uttered in
the course of this hour uh barbara
hernstein smith another colleague of
theirs that duke these are all people i
mentioned in my book uh would would also
disagree with every single syllable i
mean the the list is quite long actually
among academics
i have my fans but also many enemies if
we were to do this in 20 years from now
do you think you would um
well from your point of view would you
be winning or losing more than you are
now
um well i'd hope that i'd be winning
more but um one reason
why
well um i'm i think it's up for grabs i
think one reason i wrote this book is
that
i don't think the situation is hopeless
but i think that people have to begin to
understand what really is going on
in colleges and campuses across the
country and you know
stand up and take notice of it and try
to change it i think they can last
question other than buying your book for
1895 that harper and roe put out called
tenured radicals what can anybody
watching this do if they want to
have some impact
and agree with what you've said well
let's let's talk about parents i think a
parent should
look very closely at what their their
children are studying in colleges and
there and
they should look at the syllabuses ask
what's what the teachers are teaching
and you know they might find themselves
in for a rude surprise
our guest for the last hour has been
roger kimball this is his book tenured
radicals how politics has corrupted our
higher education thank you sir thank you
roger kimball is managing editor of new
criterion magazine and author of tenured
radicals how politics has corrupted our
higher education it's published by ivan
rd
for more information visit their website
at ivanrd.com
every weekend book tv brings you an
encore presentation of book notes on
saturdays at 7 p.m and sundays at 11 a.m
east